I'm joined today by author and
entrepreneur Andrew yang who's running
as a Democrat for president in 2020 on a
platform of universal basic income
Medicare for all and human centered
capitalism all issues I've talked quite
a bit about Andrew thanks for talking to
me today thanks for having me David it's
a pleasure to be here so let's start
with ubi
I mean I'm I I guess that it's there's
so many ways we could enter that
conversation but maybe one way would be
what specific problem
do you believe ubi solves well the most
pressing issue that people and we're
looking at the economy or focused on is
the automation of Labor where we've
automated away 4 million manufacturing
jobs in Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin between 2000 2015 and I'm
sitting here in Silicon Valley we were
about to do the same thing to workers in
retail transportation and truck driving
call centers fast-food and on and on
throughout the economy but the great
thing about universal basic income is
not just that it's necessary because
we're going through this transition but
also that it's going to improve the day
to day lives of tens of millions of
American individuals families and
households where people will be able to
pay their bills start saving some money
save for their children's education
potentially move and even start a new
business so there are a lot of upsides
to universal basic income but the thing
that certainly galvanized my attention
to it is the fact that our economy is
changing for Goods because of advancing
technology so under your plan you're
talking about a thousand bucks a month
per person $12,000 for the year would
that replace other social welfare
benefits or would it be in addition to
it would largely be in addition to it
because if you look at our social
programs right now they're not really
doing the job but we will get some money
from existing social programs because if
someone's already receiving significant
benefits it's not necessarily the case
that a thousand dollars a month would be
layered on top so for example if someone
was receiving $700 and food stamps and
housing assistance they would get Trude
up to a thousand
they decided to opt for the freedom
dividend but it's not like they'd be
getting an additional thousand dollars
so that will help bring the costs of the
universal basic income down
significantly because so many people are
currently receiving benefits I want to
talk about some of the possible reasons
why ubi may not work as well as some
think that it would and to be clear that
my audience knows I've been talking
about ubi for years and years have done
a ton of interviews about it I've also
looked into you know other possibilities
like a negative income tax different
types of tax credit situations one of my
concerns with ubi is that it wouldn't
change the underlying sort of vulture
capitalist problems that exist it
wouldn't really move us towards a
different type of economy it's just hey
everybody gets 12 K or adjusted of
course depending on the particular
circumstances and one of them may be
negative consequences would be that we
see a $19,000 full-time job or we should
is completely outrageous but if you're
getting 12 K from the government that
might allow the corporation that's
paying 19 thousand dollars for a
full-time job to be subject to less
criticism because hey it's really 31
with that other 12 K yeah so there are a
couple of points in there David and I
you know I know you you're one of the
first people who figured out that
universal basic income could be an
incredible way to advance our society
over time so the the if you think about
it we're experiencing these epic gains
from new technologies with Amazon and
Google and these other companies
harvesting incredible profits really for
themselves and so universal basic income
is a great way to distribute that bounty
throughout society and while you're
right that there are dynamics of this
winner-take-all economy that universal
basic income won't address it seems to
me like that universal basic income
would make it so that everyone can share
in the dividends of progress quite
directly and so if you imagine how it
could work out in ideal world people are
able to build a more human centered
economy in their communities and then as
technology and
proves people are getting more and more
of those gains and this is the first big
step in that direction in terms of
corporations and people possibly having
to take less money I think that uh you
should look at it from the ground up
which is that people would no longer be
forced to take an abusive or
exploitative job because at this point
they can just go home and you know live
off of the thousand bucks a month if
worse comes to worst but also that
people would be able to determine for
themselves what kind of work that they
want to do and as a serial entrepreneur
I know that more and more people would
do things that they care about in their
community they did end up doing work
that would help move themselves and
their families and our society forward
more so than if they are forced to take
a job just to survive I guess that's
where I'm less sure because I guess I'm
unsure whether a thousand bucks a month
in a lot of parts of this country is
really the difference between having to
take the 19 thousand or $22,000
full-time job or not in other words it's
we can't give everybody fifty thousand
right the numbers just don't work but at
the same time I'm just not sure that the
twelve thousand actually provides people
that freedom at least not in a lot of
parts of this country well your based in
Boston I believe like I'm based in New
York and there are certainly parts of
the country where a thousand dollars
goes very very far I mean it's the
equivalent of getting paid $6 an hour
full-time which is not that far off from
what many people are surviving on and
I've spent years in Ohio and Alabama and
Michigan and I was stunned at how how
reasonable the housing could be on a
thousand dollars a month but but the
other thing is what you're proposing
really is that everyone's working for
like a handful of corporations that will
then try and grind costs down which is
true that is what many large
corporations would be driven to do but
you have to think about the way an
economy would look in a town let's say
of a 50,000 people where all of a sudden
lives another 60 million dollars in
discretionary income I mean you'd be
looking at many businesses on Main
Street and and artisanal type businesses
that would become much more
and strengthened if everyone had more
purchasing power and so it's not that
everyone would be doing some job for
some giant conglomerate we'd actually
see this incredible proliferation of
small businesses and Main Street
businesses around the country and those
are the jobs that people would end up
filling well that gets me into my other
concern directly and I'm kind of glad
you brought it up which is that there
III think that there you know a lot of
big CEO entrepreneurial types have said
I want you bi we've heard it from Mark
Zuckerberg we've heard it from I think
Jeff Bezos Elon mocking a lot long list
of my concern is that even though on
paper you might have a community like
you said you might say hey this you know
Worcester Massachusetts there's now an
additional forty million dollars of
money available which is going to go
back into the local businesses a lot of
that money I believe is gonna go back
into app purchases and Netflix and
Amazon Prime subscription zand games and
I think that while there is definitely
some altruism among some of the
billionaires that are saying they like
this idea a lot of them know that a lot
of that extra money is going to go to
them and not to their local communities
and I wonder if that's a concern to you
well if you think about it you know if
you think about your own spending if I
gave you a thousand dollars a month it'd
be actually quite difficult to spend all
of that on new apps and media
consumption so a lot of it would go
towards car repairs taking your kid out
to a movie you know like a little bit of
savings for someone's college education
I mean a lot of the money would flow
towards things that make the world go
round
in real life and the thing like it's
unfortunate that people look at the
motivations of folks who are advocating
for universal basic income as a way to
somehow question the merits of the idea
because we are talking about plowing
hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
purchasing power into the hands of the
American people that are struggling
every day to make ends meet I mean the
underemployment
recent college graduates is up to 44%
with school loans at a record 1.4
trillion
me that's crippling our younger
generation I know you're familiar with
this 59% of Americans right now camp an
unexpected $500 bill so think about the
difference that universal basic income
would make in people's day-to-day lives
the folks in technology mean you could
say like oh they're just trying to like
you know make their own businesses more
socially acceptable which may totally be
the case but they're also closest to the
scene of the automation of jobs they see
their own incentives they see their own
organizations and they're trying to send
up a red flag saying look guys what
we've done in the past will not work
moving forward and we need to think much
much bigger besides that though the
suicides I think you're right if Mark
Zuckerberg wants you bi that is not an
attack on the merits of you bi that
being said that being said it's true
that if you see a particular group of
people advocating for it it's important
to think about the ways in which they
might benefit that are not completely
obvious to us in evaluating the totality
of the idea I don't think there's
anything wrong with that well you know
and the thing that you you're pointing
out is something I could not agree more
with is that more people need to get
excited about universal basic income and
the difference would make in their
communities women should look at it and
say hey this would be a way to recognize
and compensate women for all of the
uncompensated work that's done in our
households and communities everyday
women would benefit more because women
unfortunately get paid less and have
lower levels of savings so women should
say universal basic income is great for
women people of color should look at
this and say hey we have less access to
opportunities and last wealth one study
showed that african-american households
in America would have a median net worth
of zero by 2050 so people of color
should be saying hey universal basic
income is great for us we need to take
the baton from the tech CEOs and bring
it to every other community and say this
is great for Humanity this is great for
a society and let's make it happen and
that's why I'm running for president
other angle I want to approach this from
it and get your feedback too there is a
proposal being developed
economists at London University called
universal basic services what they argue
is that if you focus on specific
services rather than just cash that
you're gonna more directly meet the
needs for people that have the lowest
income and they argue that you deliver
more value for the same expenditure if
you for example deliver health care to
someone that doesn't have it versus cash
in the same amount of the services they
might otherwise be purchasing can you
talk a little bit about why you think
that a flat ubi is better than a service
based approach sure there are at least
three reasons - the first is that we've
been trying to administer it in some
ways a services based approach over the
years and it just hasn't worked where
you know like you you have vouchers for
housing vouchers for food vouchers for
education in some cases and we've seen
that our programs aren't actually
elevating people out of their situations
in many cases they have perverse
incentives attached to them where if
they start to flourish then you don't
get it anymore
so one has got to look at what's working
too is you have to look at what our
government is actually capable of where
so for example some politicians might
say we need to educate and retrain
Americans for the jobs of the future
ignoring the fact that independent
studies show the efficacy levels of
government sponsored retraining to be
close to 0% so if you plow more money
into for example education programs that
may not work as opposed to giving people
purchasing power that in my mind is us
talking ourselves into coverage being
able to do things that it's not going to
be able to do and the third thing is
that there is a real axe as an
administration issue where if you have
services inevitably there ends up being
some kind of mechanical and elaborate
process to access those services and
many people end up struggling with that
getting excluded and there at their end
up being people that you know don't get
what they're supposed to get under
whatever program we devise where a
straight cash is going to deliver
on purchasing power where its most
needed and people will be able to attend
to their needs most directly from a
legal perspective andrew yang becomes
president is it executive order is it a
bill that is developed by Congress how
do you make this a legal reality well
the great thing is that all you need is
a majority of Congress and if I'm
president there will likely have been a
blue wave and so we'll be looking at a
democratic LED Congress and if the guy
who's running on universal basic income
becomes president we all know what's
gonna happen next which is that the
Congress is gonna get together and we're
going to start rolling it out so what
most people don't realize is that this
passed the House of Representatives in
1971 under Richard Nixon and it stalled
in the Senate because of a Democratic
Congress Democratic senators I wanted a
higher income threshold so there is not
any massive legal step one needs to take
it's really just an act of Congress and
something exactly analogous has been in
effect in Alaska for 36 years and it's
wildly popular in a Republican state so
this is much more feasible and
achievable than most people believe
we've been speaking with Andrew yang
he's an author and entrepreneur running
as a Democrat for president in 2020 the
platform is based on universal basic
income Medicare for all and human
centered capitalism Andrew really great
to talk to you have been following your
work for some time and it's so great to
be able to talk to you about it
well David it was great great being here
and please let's make this a regular
occurrence I'm a big fan of yours in
your work thank you let's do it